[Musique]
mélanie vous allez nous parler un petit
peu de hausse du dollar de la table
recevoir bien recevoir à terme est parti
alors déjà bien recevoir emparée de
toute décoration de table parce que pour
faire sa décoration de table il faut
penser avant tout à son mobilier s'en
inspirer par exemple sur les images que
l'on va voir à l'écran les scénographes
du cfa de saint germain en laye se sont
inspirés du tapis un tapis qui peut
faire penser à un parquet et qui est de
style moderne mais on peut aussi jouer
avec l'esprit de la pièce là cette table
est dressée au coeur du domaine de
madame elisabeth qui est donc très
classique plutôt royal il fallait donc
apporter une certaine touche
contemporaine
comment ce que les gens pensent pas
c'est que c'est c'est pas une décoration
de table c'est une décoration de table
dans une pièce donc si vous faites une
décoration qui n'a absolument rien à
voir avec tout le décor que vous avez à
côté vous risquez de passer à côté
ici la vaisselle on a fait un choix de
du départ et âge pour les assiettes mais
il faut absolument avoir quand même un
fil conducteur vous ne peut pas tout
départ est alors le petit conseil de
laurent tanguy c'est aussi d'anticiper
les décorations en fonction des dépôts
de plat alors surtout ne changez pas
votre table de décoration puisque si
vous allez les enlever juste avant de
manger c'est un peu dommage
vous allez gâcher leur pack vos convives
si on doit poser des plats dessus on va
pouvoir décorer tout autour de découvert
le set de table le verre l'acier tapin
et garder la partie centrale
relativement vide ou si comme
aujourd'hui
alors on va utiliser tout l'espace et la
tendance de cette année c'est le végétal
et oui car la nature de manière subtile
wilfried on va amener un peu de gaieté
pourquoi ne pas récupérer les feuilles
tombées des arbres dès bouts de bois des
branches des pommes de pin mais il faut
choisir un élément pour le décliner sous
différentes formes au positionnement
coucher poser recouvert etc
alors les végétaux peuvent même servir
de rom serviette pour cette table
décoration à base d'animaux dans des
petits pots carré
deux techniques sont possibles lautoka
l'âge c'est à dire que les fleurs
se tiennent entre elles grâce au vase
est la technique la plus simple c'est la
technique la plus simple pardon ou alors
on peut aussi utiliser de la pousse de
fleuriste épique et les fleurs dedans en
important pour un centre de table c'est
qu'il faut pas trop là autant maximum
par rapport au sol à la table c'est 30
centimes est un principe élémentaire
vraiment déjà assez haut il faut pas que
les convives sur un génie par des fleurs
mais il existe une exception
nous pouvons très bien avoir une coupe
sur pied très route avec une composition
tout en hauteur mais au niveau du visuel
il faut que les convives puissent
toujours recevoir
alors attention la décoration de table
n'est pas forcément un centre de table
on peut totalement l'excentré là bien
sûr une important bien sûr où le fric
vous en doutez c'est de se faire plaisir
et de partager un bon repas
voilà pour ces quelques conseils que
vous pourriez nous donner
[Musique]